mr. alert here's a map of the property  don't need it it's already been scanned  locked and loaded sir yeah that way had  that upside down when I scanned it  that's why on you how'd you put it good  on one of those things we're known to  dabble monkey hopping it missed it still  got it come on dad it's a vacation try  to enjoy it someone's taken down the  hotel  your uniform as requested officer Blart  will need me back up the lot neither do  i if being a security officer was easy  anybody could do it takes a certain  breed someone who has spidey-senses and  [ __ ] that's clean glass we are trained  to detect deter observe and report  but there's one man who goes above and  beyond  oh sweet mercy I am so sorry ma'am are  you gonna want turndown service you know  what you just did jaywalked in a  business district sir actually it's uh  officer still giving me a ticket she's  gonna give you my phone number case you  want to grab a drink sometime I don't  drink but do ride  you